here's a tweet from Jen Smokey and of
course you remember Jan saki she was the
chief liar at the White House White
House Press Secretary and she tweeted
this out she's now an MSNBC
correspondent because when you lie for a
living in the government the next thing
you do is get a cushy high-paying job at
a corporate news Outlet she wrote holy
moly Sienna New York Times poll more
than a third of independent voters and
smaller but noteworthy contingent of
Democrats said they were open to
supporting candidates who reject the
legitimacy of the 2020 election as they
focus on economic issues well that's my
God she must be freaking out why would
people how bizarre that people might
support candidates who have talked about
stolen elections before well Glenn
Greenwald who is a lefty uh you know
he's I would say he's shifting a little
bit maybe he's a little bit say where I
was a couple years ago but certainly a
lefty no one is thinking this guy's a
republican right uh he had a thread
about some of the things that Democrats
have said because saki's freaking out oh
my God how could people vote for people
who would contest elections he had a
great threat on people that support
people who contest elections uh here's a
tweet from Corinne Jean-Pierre back in
uh you're not going to believe this
2016. uh stolen emails stolen drone
stolen election welcome to the world of
unprecedented Trump yeah stolen election
she said it there herself you see it
stole an election she now works for the
White House he continued in this thread
since I've been writing about politics
Democrats have been denying election
outcomes it was basically Universal
among liberals that bush Cheney stole
the 2000 election many believe that
about 2004 Ohio and Rove two-thirds of
Dems believed Russian hackers converted
Hillary voters to Trump yeah that's true
it continues one of the most admired
Democrats in the country you guys know
this one Stacy Abrams refused is to
concede her 2018 loss in the Georgia
gubernatorial race insisting that she is
the real winner and that Republicans
cheated to win the media ignores this
whole story when using election deniers
that really of course is the point you
guys also know that Hillary Clinton
tweeted out uh during Donald Trump's
presidency that he was an illegitimate
president and by golly we've even got
video I believe he knows he's an
illegitimate president he knows he knows
that there were a bunch of different
reasons why the election turned out the
way it did
laughs
like in retrospect now listening to that
and and that so many people bought into
it he knows he's illegitimate there were
a bunch of reasons I don't have to get
into the reasons but there was a whole
freaking bunch of them you know there's
a lot of them what are we doing here